yo what's up this is ice cute it's time
to go undercover on the Internet
this is actually me let's start with
twitter here we go I want to know what
Ice Cube said that made Drake charge his
DAP up like this well I just ripped the
crowd who was at the Forum 15,000 people
I have to check yourself a good day
you'd run up and dab me up like that to
post that [ __ ] [ __ ]
let's see got this for Christmas I love
it but I want to know if homie Ice Cube
got his check no I didn't get my check I
need my check for this yeah I got a few
pointers for you too
must have called me after I just woke up
smoking a blunt why is Ice Cube always
mad in the movies laugh out loud why do
you think and all that laughing you're
doing I'll shut all that down we
laughing out loud on me
I bet Ice Cube is mad at the braiders
I'm no longer an oak the Raiders aren't
Oakley man so I don't know what you talk
about and I'm mad they not in their Lake
in Oakland they plan a prison come
playing there laying that new stadium
Lee boom he's go to the next one
Instagram officially on the Internet
what the hell what's going on man why
you got to get me over the nipple man
next time put me on I'm the muscle man
my damn nipple no respect man you must
be a fan appreciate it's actually good I
like this it's sweet damn they look like
me I mean flesh tones and everything the
bandana it look 3d
response transmitting
reddit it's actually me oh yeah was an
ice cube on Sesame Street once hey Elmo
hell yeah I grew up on Sesame Street and
I was proud to be on Sesame Street I'm
og witty you know me
Charlie day the white version of Kevin
are
oh lord have mercy nobody wanted to be
the white version of Kevin Hart nobody
wanted to be the black version of Kevin
Hart I love the line last week [ __ ]
around and got truly dumb like who the
[ __ ] keeping stats at your playground
basketball down kid
I got money now so I can get a
statistician I got scoreboards and all
kind of stuff going on at my pick up
game so don't worry about it you know I
mean we got a camera crew got a podium
media it's what you do when you get paid
you just overdo everything and submit
Yahoo Answers his Ice Cube really did I
see a nice Cuban lady yeah both of our
parents are ice here's an ice cube the
best rapper ever I believe so ever in
the history of rhyming mother Goose to
take her ass straight out answers.com
[Music]
what is Ice Cube favorite color orange
odd no gangsta and black and he's about
to attack remembered a wicked damn team
no seriously it's actually me Jackson
pinned his first rap song in the ninth
grade after a fire challenged him to
write a song during the middle of
keyboarding effects it was called type
and class we actually had type writers
in that class this is true his name is
kiddo
he said you write when I write one we
see which one's the best now who you
think was the best kiddo didn't beat me
rapping trust me I am DB that is
actually me okay
second movie the co-star ice cube tray
they previously start together first
Sunday this is true little trivia about
that Tracy Morgan shot the whole movie
with an ankle bracelet on his damn ankle
where he if he didn't leave a set and go
straight home he was going to jail yeah
didn't know that did you
dark ministers scowling eyes more often
than not a beard
the third trademark would be simply the
best at everything I ever think of I
think that's a Donald Trump quote Koro
his Ice Cube really as badass as he
would have us believe
try me try how did Ice Cube get his name
my dumbass brother he's older than me he
threatened to slam me into a freezer
pull me out when I was the ice cube I
just started using that name and it just
caught on so I'm getting paid off of it
now who the hell you gonna throw in the
freezer now Clyde who no damn body who
was ice cube and called the Doody
I forgot the name of Kari I don't I
don't know man you tell me you got
Google Chris Tucker and Ice Cube really
smoking weed in the Wiis scenes in the
movie Friday what you think
make it a fish you - yo what's up this
is Ice Cube is Ice Cube ever smile of
course I do
wait is he really in call of duty
yeah just look at my ass on Quora
there's ice cube ever age hell yeah you
don't see no jheri curl no more dude you
just rocked a jheri curl didn't handle
hair on my face blast - is he wearing
who the hell's this
especially Rough Rider Jersey no that is
actually a made of jerk no team at all I
just like the colors
Moe guy who answers are they th ey bruh
going to make another Friday
I stood who are that I mean are you
asking me am I gonna make another Friday
I want to make another Friday we trying
to put it together takes time to do
something great remember that all right
what are the best ice cube songs to be
gangsta to all of them every last one of
them you can be gangster - it was a good
day
ice cube was from the East Coast would
he be less popular know worldwide baby
worldwide West Side so even if I'm on
the East Coast you know where it is
it's the West Side when I'm there if I
go to Rome you know where Rome is it's
the West Side when I get there South
Africa is the West Side when I get there
remember that how you like that
experience damn Internet zombies that
was me yeah I skew right here actually
important don't you